άλλ κάποιο να θέλουν το σεοκτώ άλον το τρτόνομα άρχει τοτη συζηήτήλο και τα λίβα
γιατα λιβ εγώ αφερώτο το αυτό που πότ συήτησει τω αφέρως από κα πρσίμερα έλα
παραδωσιακά αντπαλος σε σαωιά πάντα του συναγεμού σε όλες τεπιλοκές διαδικασίες ήταν το άκε αιφτάσαμε
στην περίοδον όπου αντίπαλς σεσαικά πάντα είναι το ελά χουμε τι θέμα αντίπαλος του δημοκρατικού
συναγερμού ήταν είναι και θα είναι ολακισμόο απόου και ν προέρχεται όποια δήποτε μύρεαλιστική λύση
όποια δποτε μήρεαλιστική προσπάθεια είτα στην οικονομία είτ στα πράγματα που συζητήσαμε λίγον προηγούμένος είτα
με οποιο δήποτε άλλον τρόπο προτείνει λύσεις οι οποίες δεν ενπεριέχουν αλήθεια αλλά εν περιέχουν
συνέσθημα δηλαδή ξεια πάλα στην τορ όλες ηλύσεις οι ανθρώπι νες εριέχουν και συνέσημα δε
δεν υπάστε κόπιούτες ούτε να κάμουμε τον κότοκοπιοτες για να καταλάβε όμως πρέπει να φέρνουν
και αποτέλεσα οεί να είναι μη ρεαλιστικιας όδημοκρατικός συναγερμός αντιτήθεται και πρέπει να αντιτήθεται και
εγώ έτσι μεγάλωσα έτσι μαθαμεστούν τον κόμπα πρέπει να αντιήθε σε όποιαδήποτε δύναμη όποιαντίποτε δύναμη
απευθύνεται στο συνέσθημα του κόσμου χωρίς αποτέλεσμα λέω το βάζζω σ λίο τοα υπάρχουν στελέχει
του ημοκρατικούς συναγερμού και στελέχει όχι τυχιατλέχειτη τελέχειτη τις ου ήταν μέχρι πρότινος στις πρώτης
γράμμης δηλαή σας φοβιίζει αυτόν ότι στέλσς τελεχεή που ήτα τον καιό συναγερμόν και πλέουν
είνε το έλα όχι αυτός σας προβλημα έλεξη επέλεξα επέλεξαν επέλεξαν κι τη ριτορική και
τ